my life is very good right now very
excited priyanka chopra and nick jonas's
daughter officially has a name e.t can
confirm the couple named their baby girl
malty marie chopra jonas the name pays
homage to the actress's indian heritage
multi in sanskrit means small fragrant
flower or moonlight the little one was
born shortly after 8 pm on january 15th
at a san diego hospital this is a
special thing in january both stars
surprised fans when they shared the news
on instagram that they'd welcomed a
bundle of joy they wrote we are
overjoyed to confirm that we have
welcomed a baby via surrogate we
respectfully ask for privacy during this
special time as we focus on our family
thank you so much
in march we learned more about how the
duo is adapting to life as mom and dad
our source explains they love being new
parents and spend a lot of time at home
and that this is something they've
wanted for a while it's been a great
couple months priyanka nick are private
but have let close friends and family
meet their baby we can assume that
includes nick's brother kevin and his
two daughters and his other brother joe
jonas has one daughter and another baby
on the way with wife sophie turner you
know you love seeing
your family happy and with all those
little cousins running around naked
priyanka's daughter will have plenty of
company i read recently you said you
wanted to have a cricket sized family
what does nick think about that does he
want maybe a chess team instead or maybe
a basketball team i mean cricket that's
what like 11 players come on now free
yeah that was a statement i made many
years ago i don't know you know i'll
take whatever i can get when it comes to
nick and i by the time the holidays
arrive little malty will be nearly a
year old but first they'll celebrate
their first holiday season as a family
of three when it spoke with priyanka in
december she shared her favorite part of
that magical time of the year i think
we're still about building traditions
our big tradition is trying to spend
christmas together
because we're always doing so many
things apart but just being home with
the family that's all
[Music]